hey youtubers is Charlie really awesome
one-punch news so it's making its
english-language debut on Toonami next
week so I'm gonna do a quick explainer
for what one punches and why everybody
loves it so much it was big it was like
the best anime to premiere last year
important stuff first if you've been
watching or reading one punch man then
you know that it just ended its
12-episode season one run but the
english-language dub version isn't
debuting until next week July 16th so
it's a really good opportunity if you
have friends that do not typically watch
anime to get into it because it is
probably the best new anime in a long
time it's the anime that people who have
been watching anime for a long time are
really excited about because it's kind
of like the Deadpool of Shonen manga
because even though there are a lot of
really awesome anime series like Dragon
Ball full metal alchemist one piece
they also come to very similar tropes so
just like Deadpool became a very post
comic book character someone the writers
could use to make fun of other comic
book writers in all comics in general
just for doing a lot of the same things
over and over with characters having the
same character types having the same
character arcs so in each episode of one
punch man they kind of take on a
different character like they take on
piccolo in Episode one with vaccine man
so naturally the first episode
completely roasts Dragon Ball in the
idea of the overpowered hero so you know
what happens when you start to see the
same thing over and over with characters
and arcs you get really tired of it so
one of the reasons why people really
love one punch is because satyam the
protagonist is just really tired of it
all he's like I'm so bored by all these
fights he just mows through his enemies
like it's no big deal so it's really
more of a comedy parody series like
Deadpool is in the comics in that way so
if you're a big fan of the way the
Deadpool character works even if you've
only seen the movie you have them
greeting Deadpool in the comics or
anything like that this is a really good
gateway drug into anime because you
don't necessarily need to understand all
the tropes that it's making fun of in
order to enjoy it like it's just funny
by itself but it works on so many
different levels like you have this meta
commentary about how all Shonen anime
has gotten tired and boring because like
for instance you find out the secret to
Satyam is power
hands up finding this Android and
eventually the Android asked him how did
you get so powerful and you're expecting
this really grand reveal like oh my god
he's going to tell him the secret of how
he became the most powerful person in
the world and he says I did 100 pushups
100 sit-ups 100 squats in a 10k run
every single day which is like the most
boring explanation ever so the joke is
is that say domotics it's this really
big deal but it's just the stupidest
thing ever so all of one punch is really
this smart send-up of anime in a very
Deadpool type way Deadpool is just the
example I'm using because a lot of you
are familiar with them from the movies
are from the comics in the way that you
is a meta character that makes fun of
all comic book characters in all
superhero films so one punch does that
for anime and manga so it's like a
really good gateway drug in next week
starting on the 16th it's going to make
its english-language dub debut on
Toonami
so if you've never watched it or if you
want to watch it again or if you have
friends that don't watch anime it is the
perfect series to make them join your
cult without realizing it and if you're
not sure about season 2 there will be a
one-punch season 2 but just like attack
on titan the creators are like oh my god
this is amazingly popular of course
we're going to do a season 2 but they
didn't set a date so just to be
determined so while I'm not expecting it
to be an attack on Titan situation where
we do have to wait four years to get
season 2 I do think that it's too late
in the year for them to get any episodes
out this year so probably like next year
fall at the earliest and you know could
be a little bit later than that so just
brace yourself for a delay for season 2
of 1 punch but if you do want to see it
faster I think probably the ways that
you can support it or either to buy the
manga watch it on vis watch the
english-language dub when it drops on
Toonami that's really the best way to
let the network's know hey like you know
people want to see this we'll get season
2 out faster that in yelling at them on
social media although maybe that first
methods a little bit better but let me
know in the comments what do you guys
think of one punch do you like the way
that it just completely roasts all these
other anime series but hopefully now
like if you've never seen it or you've
never read the manga you understand why
people won't shut up about it
even old angry anime watchers who are
completely burnt out on the genre have
come back to it now because of this like
this is what gets really old grumpy pee
to watch anime again so I don't really
have any like weekly one-punch videos
planned or anything like that I might do
like one more just for the season in
general but you know I pretty much
summed up my thoughts on it already in
this video but if you guys do want me to
do more anime videos just let me know in
the comments there is a new episode of
Boozer con Friday but a lot of people
feel like it's kind of a dumpster fire
so we'll see how that goes and for those
of you that are asking about attack on
tight like I posted the attack on Titan
video a couple days about season two I
will make weekly videos when that comes
back but like I said in the video it's
not going to premiere til spring 2017 so
that's a long ways away so be sure to
subscribe to get everything I'm totally
open to doing anime videos but a lot of
it just depends on what everyone's
feelings are on each series what you
guys wait for my next video to post you
can click here to learn all about attack
on Titan season 2 they finally confirmed
a premiere date it should have premiered
last year and you can click here to
learn all about Iron Man passing the
mantle to a 15 year old girl there's
going to be a 15 year old girl that will
be Ironman this fall so thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you